Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Ist auch mal wieder richtig morgen. Es fühlt sich an wie morgen, finde ich.
Jetzt haben wir sogar Schnee, der ist liegen geblieben. Es war ein Bild für die Götter, als ich heute zur Metaebene kam und der stand da im guten, alten englischen Anorak, kratzte das Fahrzeug frei, auf das die Nachbarn nicht blöd gucken.
Ja, man muss ja auch schon ein bisschen drauf achten, wenn man so wahrgenommen wird, ne?
Das ist.
Äh ja, nicht, dass es irgendwie dreckig ist oder so, was der Geier, was die Leute denken.
Man soll ja auch zeigen, was man hat, wenn da der ganze Schnee drauf liegt, ne? Ja, warum sollen wir dich zeigen, wenn's einem gut geht?
Genau. Na ja, aber nach dem Pulieren habe ich dann doch noch Zeit gehabt für eine Sendung.
Wieso der Pole poliert doch immer noch da draußen das Auto.
Findest du nicht, dass guten Morgen eigentlich auch ein schöner eigentlich ein sehr positive Ausrichtung aus dieser Sendung? Ich meine, das ist doch das, was wir uns wünschen, ne? Man könnte sagen, ein Gutes, gutes Morgen. Vielleicht sollte ich gutes Morgen sagen.
Gutes Wochenende.
zum Abschluss der Sendung. Wir wünschen, ich wünsche dir ein gutes Morgen.
Ja, so ist es. Aber wir hatten schon mal lustigere Intros. Kommen wir äh, kommen wir zum Inhalt. Haben wir welchen?
Nee, wir äh wir können ja einfach noch ein, wir können ja jetzt auf äh biegen und brechen, versuchen, noch irgendwas Lustiges zu sagen. Nee, nee, das klappt nicht. Klappt nicht, ne? Nee. Nee.
Nee, nee, das klappt nicht. Nee. Nee. Lass uns lieber hier zu den äh Face-Pimes der internationalen kommen. Hier dieser äh äh sagenumwobene äh Weltkongress, der internationalen Fernmelderunion. Die ITU.
Ich muss da immer, ich musste immer in einen ganz anderen Weltkongress denken, aber der ja, also der Weltkongress, der der.
Der Fernmeldetechnischen Internationale.
Ja, der existierte, äh, die, wir haben da ja schon öfter drauf hingewiesen so und es war immer so ganz unklar, was das ist und jetzt endlich,
haben sich die Geister einige ähm einige gute Artikel zu, äh die über das Geschehen dort berichtet haben. Insbesondere äh ist da auf jeden Fall hervorzuheben, der von Patrick Beuth,
bei Zeit Online der da so ein bisschen zusammengefasst hat was da überhaupt der Stand ist und auch ein bisschen einfach einschätzt,
Wie groß ist die Gefahr jetzt äh wirklich von von unseren von unseren was da was da passiert? Ähm,
Wir hatten das ja, glaube ich, schon so ein bisschen zusammengefasst, irgendwie ihren letzten Standard, hat die ITU irgendwie neunzehnhundertachtundachtzig verabschiedet und entsprechend war das noch so ein bisschen.
Seit neunzehnhundertachtundachtzig keinen Standard mehr verabschiedet.
Oder vielleicht haben die, also zumindest diesen diesen neuen Vertrag, den sie da jetzt irgendwie schaffen wollen, haben sie der der letzte Stand davon, wahrscheinlich haben sie neue Standard.
Aber ich meine, die ITO macht doch auch gar keine Standards in dem eigentlichen Sinne.
Was machen die denn? Die einigen, doch, die einigen sich doch auf äh auf Regeln, ja, also sie haben ihre letzte große Standardkonferenz war irgendwie neunzehnhundertachtundachtzig, wo die sich da alle getroffen haben,
Jetzt müssen sie irgendwie was machen und wollen jetzt irgendwie auch mal mit Internet. Ne?
und äh ja war ja schon wurde ja immer schon drüber gelacht, seit hundertfünfzig Jahren gibt's die und die definieren diese Standards für Telegraphie äh und Telefonie deshalb, damit sie irgendwie international kommunizieren können, ne, dass das alles irgendwie funktioniert.
Der hier ist von Vollzugsordnungen die Rede. Also es geht da sozusagen sehr viel mehr um die ähm,
Na die internationale Abstimmung, keine Ahnung, sozusagen. Das Organisatorische Management.
Genau, wie die wie die irgendwie ihren, ihren Kram da so grob äh unter Kontrolle halten. Und was jetzt äh was jetzt also äh Vorschläge sind, wenn man da jetzt mal so das das grobe Lagebild betrachtet, äh,
Gibt es da jetzt eben Vorschläge von einigen, die von einigen Ländern, die die Kontrolle der Nationalstaaten in diesem Internet erhöhen wollen? Also ähnlich
wie sie's eigentlich auch bei ihrem, bei ihrem Telefoniesystem hatten. Äh ich hatte das bei unserem Auftritt bei den Datenspuren auch schon mal so genannt, dass das natürlich im Interesse Telekommunikationsanbieter zum Beispiel ist, sowas wie
ein Ferngespräch zu haben oder ein ein Auslandsgespräch, was dann eben mehr kostet, ja? Und,
Allerlei wirre an Vorschläge wie irgendwie Staatengrenzen, die Kontrolle von E-Mails, dann würden sie ganz gerne die Domains selber vergeben,
Ähm statt das von der ICAN organisieren zu lassen, welche top level Domains es gibt und so und,
Ähm da haben sie also allerlei krude Ideen,
irgendwie da darüber die Kontrolle an dieses Internet an sich zu reißen. Das Problem, was dabei natürlich existiert, wenn jetzt irgendwelche, wenn jetzt sowas verabschiedet wird, wie,
Was weiß ich, Provider können auf einmal einfach mal nach Gutdünken, nationale Top-Level Domains machen oder so, das das damit dieser gesamt diese gesamte Idee des
internationalen Internets äh verloren geht, wenn da irgendwie nationale Interessen äh reingemischt werden. Ähm.
Weil's so top Level Domains, die sozusagen nur in einem Land gelten.
Ja oder überhaupt, dass überhaupt mal irgendwie jemand nach Gutdünken eine Top-Level Domain machen kann, ja? Also das geht ja nicht so einfach. Ich habe hier auch schon mal, ich werde hier auch gerne eine top Level, habe ich aber nicht bekommen.
Ja, nur AVM darf das. Punkt Box gilt überall.
Ja, so also es äh wie kennst du eigentlich den genauen Prozess, so eine Top-Level Domain zu äh irgendwie ist ein riesiger Abstimmungs.
Kommen, tut man die sowieso nicht, sondern äh äh die muss halt beschlossen werden und da müssen sich dann halt irgendwie einig sein und äh es gab da ja schon verschiedenste äh äh Versuche immer mal wieder diese und jede durchzubringen.
auch geschafft. Ich meine, es gibt ernsthaft so was wie Punkt Museum und äh so, ja, also das ist einfach vollkommen albern. Benutze auch keinen Schwanz,
weil es irgendwie auch gar kein Epil hat. Ich meine, das einzige, was wirklich sinnvoll wäre, wäre, quasi alles Mögliche zu eröffnen,
aber damit ist eigentlich auch keinem wirklich so geholfen. Also es ist schon äh etwas merkwürdig, hat auch natürlich auch damit zu tun, dass es, glaube ich, keine wirklich klar etablierte Vorstellung davon gibt,
Zumindest jetzt alle Leute teilen würden, was genau eine Top-Level Domain nun eigentlich zu leisten hat. Ja, ich meine, schon dot com ist irgendwie absurd,
Also was was soll dort kommen sein.
Commercial, oder?
Naja klar, es war halt mal so für,
Private für kapitalistische Unternehmen, ja? Können sie auch Punkt CAP nennen? Ja, das wäre vielleicht ein Punkt.
Punkt Schweinesystem.
Punkt com. Hätten sie ja sozusagen den Kommunisten überlassen können, ja. Vielleicht ist es ja auch so, ja, wir sind da irgendwie alle unterwandert. Und ähm ne, Punkt com Punkt com.
Org für für.
Ja, überhaupt sozusagen Punkt Marx, also man könnte ja sozusagen alle,
alle Allgemein akzeptierten Staaten und äh Gesellschaftssysteme äh so die Ideen und Theorien dahinter, dann einfach auch mal eine top Level Domain gießen.
ich albere. Also es ist unklar, ja, es gibt auch Punkt AIRO, benutze auch keinen äh äh Mensch. Und natürlich hätte Coca-Cola hätte auch gerne Punkt Coca Cola, ja, oder Punkt Cola vielleicht sogar noch.
Linus, aber die hören nicht auf mich, ja.
Ja, ist schwierig, ne? Aber ich glaube, da hättest du auch schlechte Karten irgendwie in einer Punktsilos gekriegt.
Ja
Ja, fällt mir nach, mindestens eine, ein anderer Linus einfallen.
Punkt ähm XXX gibt's, glaube ich, jetzt auch, ne? Da waren, da wurden dann.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist jetzt durch. Aber auch das ist halt irgendwie.
Das ist nicht für die Kinder.
Weiß ich gar nicht, gibt's Punkte CSX?
Ich las davon. Also, OK. Behalten wir uns damit nicht unbedingt auf. Das, das Ding bei der, bei dieser, äh, WCIT, dem Weltkongress, der, der internationalen Telekommunisten, äh, ist, dass sie, ähm,
einstimmig abstimmen müssen. Das heißt, das ist eigentlich völlig egal, was Russland und China da für ein Killefit reinpumpen,
da äh eigentlich die EU die USA
geschlossen gegen solche Sachen stehen. Gerade die USA legen da besonderen, besonderen Wert drauf, auf auf diese ganzen Meinungsfreiheitsgeschichte und so und diese diese Vorschläge, die Russland und China da irgendwie reintragen. Ähm,
haben da jetzt ohnehin nicht so viel ähm so viel Aussicht darauf, dass sie sich durchsetzen.
Ja und man muss natürlich auch sagen, dass das aktuelle System in den USA schon doch deutlich mehr Einfluss äh.
Genau, die US, die USA sind nämlich froh, dass sie das Internet unter Kontrolle haben. Aber vielleicht mal kurz, das hatte Herr Patrick Beute in diesem Artikel ebenso so schön zusammengefasst, das möchte gern ich noch mal wiedergeben. Ähm,
Also wenn man jetzt nach Deutschland schaut, es sind dann sowieso immer von jedem Land gibt's dann quasi stimmberechtigt, sind wirklich nur die Länder. Aber alle möglichen äh,
Stakeholder, wie das so schön heißt, wenn man nicht Lobbyisten sagen möchte, äh fahren natürlich auch dorthin und ähm um um irgendwie dann da äh,
Für ihre Interessen zu werben. So ist zum Beispiel dann die äh die Telekom dort, die irgendwie,
irgendwie unterstützt, ja? Die möchten ganz gerne, also der Hintergrund ist, sie möchten, dass YouTube
die also jetzt als Beispiel YouTube, die natürlich für einen größeren Teil des Traffics,
verantwortlich sind, der durch Leitungen, die der Telekom gehören zu den Nutzern geht, die diesen Traffic bestellt haben, möchten also YouTube dafür zur Kasse bilden.
Ja, also sagen YouTube im Bild und Müll auf unseren Leitungen und deswegen muss YouTube dafür bezahlen. Wir hatten, wie gesagt, in der Netzneutralitätssendung sehr ausführlich erklärt, warum das eine völlig beknackte Idee ist.
Glücklicherweise übrigens, das hat mich sehr gefreut, da das Lob an Kai Biermann von der von Zeit online. Der hat ein,
Interview geführt mit den Jungs vom DIX war das, glaube ich, die dann endlich einmal sagten, ich guck mal ganz schnell,
Welche die Namen das welche Namen das waren. Genau das waren die Haraldsumme und Arnold Nipper vom Netzknoten Dezix. Also im großen deutschen Internet Exchange,
die sich dann mal dazu geäußert haben, dass dieses Modell halt auch wirklich einfach nicht,
Mit dem aktuellen Standard wirklich einfach umzusetzen sind, ne? Weil ganz ganz unklar ist, habe ich das überhaupt bestellt, ja oder äh wollte ich das überhaupt senden? Ja, also dieses dieses Modelltelefonie, es gibt jemanden, der angerufen hat
das gilt eben so nicht, ne? Gibt's ist im Internet nicht so. Zumal es grundsätzlich äh ja so ist,
Wenn ich auf YouTube gehe, dann rufe ich ja YouTube an in ja, weil YouTube redet dann halt ganz viel. Also es es gibt ja keine keine Analogie zum zum Telefon. Und dieses wurde dann auch ein
sehr schön von Herrn Nipper und Herrn Summer da in diesem Interview mit Herrn.
Meine Güte, Namen, übernahm. Sehr schön äh äh nochmal geschildert, auch aus deren Perspektive. Das fand ich sehr wichtig, dass diese da endlich mal äh auch das gesagt haben, was ich,
eh schon immer äh gesagt habe,
Nee, aber sie haben's einfach mal bestätigt. Ich ich bin ganz ehrlich, ich arbeite ja nicht am D-Six, obwohl viele glauben, dass ich äh,
Nee, das glaubt auch keiner, ne.
Dass du zumindest die Kompetenz hättest.
Verständlich, ja. Ich habe also bei mir die Fritz Fox, die läuft seit Monaten da äh ohne Update, ne. Also ist ohne, ja, wird eine Abtime, da träumen andere von. Ähm,
So, also Telekom möchte sowas machen und der Branchenverband Eco und die Bundesregierung sind dagegen. Und,
Eco möchte insgesamt das einfach nur sicherstellen, dass in diesem neuen,
ITR, das ist das Vertragswerk, auf das sie, oder das, das Standardwerk, auf das sie sich dann da einigen, International Tele Communications Regulations vermutlich. Die möchte ich einfach, dass da möglichst viel wenig übers Internet drinsteht. So und das ist einfach der Anspruch des Eco.
Die ICAN-Leute sind natürlich auch da und werben dafür, dass das äh Multi Stakeholder Modell aufrecht erhalten bleibt, also dass es,
Das Multi Stakeholder Modell äh,
Wie würde man das am am besten beschreiben? Das also, dass es nicht grade keine grobe Regulierung von oben irgendwie gibt, von den Ländern oder so, sondern dass alle.
Viele Köche halt.
Viele Köche einen einen schönen Brei machen. Ähm,
Und dann gibt es das Ethno, die European Telekom Network of äh,
Die wollen halt auch wieder dieses Modell. Also es sind alle möglichen Leute am Tisch und haben auch unterschiedliche ähm,
Also die Telekom ist ja in in mehreren Branchenverbänden, die dann auch teilweise mal wieder von der von dem Wunsch der Telekom abweichen, aber die haben eh alle nichts zu sagen. Insofern
ist das, glaube ich, einfach nur eine relativ irre Konferenz und ungefähr das spiegelt ja auch die Medienberichterstattung wieder. USA sagen klar, wir wollen die Meinungsfreiheit da drin sichern und vor allem wollen wir natürlich auch sichern, dass
unsere Gestaltungsmacht übers Internet erhalten bleibt, weil die USA natürlich einen sehr viel größeren Einfluss darauf haben,
Als andere Länder, äh Russland ähm hatte ursprünglich den Vorschlag gemacht, also der der der ursprüngliche
Das ursprüngliche Antragswerk aus Russland lautet irgendwie so, wir wollen die ICAN entmachten, wollen da Zensur einführen und einmal so alles, was was man so als als russische russische Demokratie benötigt, äh wurde wurde von den Russen gefordert.
Lupenreines Internet.
Loomreies Internet, ja? Und,
Und äh das hat aber direkt so einen Krawall gegeben, dass sie inzwischen eine entschärfte Fassung ihrer Vorschläge da eingebracht haben,
Und dann, was ich sehr spannend fand, afrikanische Länder, ähm da war jetzt so die die Überlegung, denen ist eigentlich dieses Sender, sollte dieses Sender Pace Modell erstmal gar nicht so unsympathisch sein,
weil die ja insgesamt relativ wenig,
in globalen Internet Content produzieren, das heißt wenn sie könnten in so einem Sender Pace Modell eventuell eine Möglichkeit sehen äh von Google und so weiter ihren äh oder von von YouTube oder was ihren,
Netzausbau, Quersubventionieren zu lassen. Gleichzeitig wäre es aber natürlich die absolute Wirtschaftsbremse, weil sie dann ihren ihren Traffic,
ihre Daten niemals aus dem Land kriegen, ja weil sie dann auch bei den anderen Ländern für bezahlen.
Das heißt, da hätten sie eine sehr hohe Markteintrittsbarriere in einem Markt, in dem sie eh absolut hinterherhinken.
Ja und das auch mit einer Vergangenheit, wo Markteintrittsbarrieren eigentlich so für einen Großteil äh des Elends verantwortlich sind schon seit vielen Jahrzehnten.
Genau,
Und die äh Chinesen sitzen am Tisch und sagen sowieso, wird zensieren und kontrollieren unser Intranet ja sowieso, wie wir wollen. Aber es wäre halt ganz schön, wenn das jetzt, wenn es quasi durch einen internationalen Standard
Werk in diesen ITR äh so eine internationale Legitimation hätte.
Iran hat sich nicht gemeldet. Ich meine, die sind ja jetzt schon eher aufm Weg zum Islam nett.
Bin mir sicher, dass die sich auch irgendwie zu Wort gemeldet haben. Da habe ich jetzt wenig zugefunden. Spannend ist, und da äh berichtete dann Andre gestern drüber, dass es da jetzt ein ein äh eine,
Normendefinition im Prinzip für die Inspection gibt. Wobei ich jetzt, also da weiß ich jetzt auch nicht genau, was da der,
Also ich weiß nicht, wem sie äh wem damit geholfen werden soll. Also sie haben, sie haben halt jetzt einen Standard für die Package Inspection. Nun sagen, was man damit alles machen kann.
Bis sie, also die ITU. Ja. Mhm.
Das ist die Fachgruppe siebzehn, Frage dreizehn oder sowas. Ich hatte das gestern mir noch mal alles rausgesucht. Den, das habe ich auch verlinkt, wo sie dann irgendwie sagen, ja, DPI wird so und so aufgestellt,
Und da kann man dann zum Beispiel verschiedene Serviceklassen machen, irgendwie Gold, Silber, Bronze und POP haben sie dann da in ihrem Beispiel, ja? Äh haben sie eine schöne Grafik, die haben sie wahrscheinlich, ich weiß nicht, womit haben die diese Grafik voll gemacht?
Nicht fragen.
Nicht fragen. Sieht so hammer auf jeden Fall eine schöne Grafik und da werden dann am Zeigen dann so wie man dieses Traffic Management machen kann und haben dann auch sehr spannende,
äh Ideen, ähm dass sie irgendwie äh,
Angestellte mit ihren, mit ihren mit ihren Firmen korrelieren wollen oder und irgendwie,
Copyright Protected All You Content irgendwie anders behandeln wollen und
bestimmte Dateien, also Detection Office Pacific Transford also das heißt schon ist schon sehr, sehr klar, ne? Also das wär dann,
sehr sehr spannend. Also so sie sagen einfach mal was man damit alles kann. Die Frage ist warum das da alles drin steht und ähm ich mein,
Ich weiß auch nicht so, das DPI wird ja von anderen hergestellt, ja? Also es wird ja von den äh Network-Operator, äh von den
nennt man die dann glaube ich. Von den Wenders hergestellt, die also sagen wir, wir liefern euch einen Switch und der kann DPI,
Und die setzen ja den de facto Standard. Also ich es scheint es gibt jetzt keinen kein großartigen Sinn, dass die international sich Leute hinsetzen und sagen das ist die PI, das das kann das. Dann ist das DPI.
Na, macht schon Sinn.
Ich meine, in dem Moment, wo du deine deine Zensuranweisung sozusagen auch anderen Ländern unterschieben willst, brauchst du natürlich schon irgendwie auch mindestens eine einheitliche Sprachregelung so und so eine Definition, gerade im Sinne von was ist erlaubt, was ist nicht erlaubt oder was möchte ich, dass du das jetzt auch für mich tust oder so, ne?
Interessant, dass dieser Grafik dann so auf die einzelnen Protokolle so als einzelne Kabel ausgeführt sind und so weiter, die sie dann gerne durchschneiden wollen, vermutlich, ne.
Also ich denke, was.
Für eine Angst äh einjagt, ne?
Was gegen, ja,
Aber interessant ist, dass du sagst, äh anderen Ländern, ich meine, es gibt nicht so viele Hersteller für für Netzwerktechnik. Wenn du mit irgendeinem, wenn du mit einem anderen äh Netzwerk,
Weil in einem anderen Land sprichst, da steht genau der gleiche Kram wie überall sonst auch. Es waren ich frage mich grade,
Ja Huawei macht doch auch äh also die den entsprechenden Kram. Also DPI wird eh überall drin sein und das ist jetzt schon ganz klar, dass das in jeder neuen Generierte-Gerätegeneration einfach äh so vorgesehen ist. Aber okay
Also das Entscheidende ist, den ich.
Zeit für vollverschlüsseltes Internet.
Aber ein wichtiges Zitat und ich habe jetzt, weiß leider nicht genau, wo ich es gelesen habe, ähm.
Internet vermutlich.
Im Internet äh Zitat von Roger Dinkel Dein, der äh wiederum.
Zeichenstorktivist et cetera.
Genau, der jemand anderen fragte äh und sagte, hör mal hier, ihr stellt doch hier diese dieses ganze Vailansequipment äh her. Ich glaube, das hat das war in dem Artikel von Andre und der dann antwortete, ja klar,
Aber äh Entschuldigung, das sind noch hier die West äh die westlichen äh Wenders, die das
das herstellen und äh die wir bauen das doch auf Anfrage von westlichen Ländern und dann verkaufen wir das Gerät eben auch in andere Länder. Aber dass wir überhaupt DPI gebastelt haben, das war doch nicht, weil die Iraner das haben wollen.
Da wussten die noch gar nicht, dass sie das haben wollten.
Da wussten sie es noch gar nicht, bis dann irgendwann mal einer mit dem äh mit dem Prospekt nach da drüben gefahren ist und gesagt hat, guck mal hier, wir haben hier ein schönes Gerät und das kann das übrigens auch.
Ja, also auf jeden Fall äh so wie's aussieht, haben sie diesen Standard ähm da jetzt für für DPI verabschiedet und äh,
Ja, ich denke, dass das am am allgemein geschehen,
wenig ändern wird, ob sie den haben oder nicht, weil das das Zeug wird trotzdem gebaut, aber ähm.
Gut. Die Konferenz.
Ist ein schlechtes Signal,
Ja, die ist äh, glaube ich, bis Ende nächster Woche noch. Also, es war ein relativ langer Zeitraum. Elfter bis bis ich hatte das in der letzten Folge, glaube ich, gesagt.
Ja, aber ich hab's vergessen.
Ich auch, aber ich glaube, das war irgendwas mit einer zwei vorne. Also, ich glaube, zwei.
Aber beschlossen ist sozusagen noch nichts und du gehst jetzt auch nicht davon aus, dass irgendwas äh finsteres beschlossen wird? Oder ist das noch offen?
Also so wie ich die Situation im Moment interpretiere, wir werden sicherlich alle möglichen finsteren Sachen beschlossen, aber die werden zunächst mal,
sieht es nicht danach aus, als hätten sie den den riesigen Impact, dass die jetzt da wirklich das Internet äh komplett umbauen, ja.
Komplett halten.
Da haben wir dann, da können wir uns dann wahrscheinlich doch auf den Dissens verlassen, der da drin herrscht, weil sie müssen halt Einheit, die müssen halt sich einigen.
Sind sie noch nicht ausreichend einig, wie sehr sie das alles äh in die Scheiße reiten wollen, so.
Genau.
Okay, gut, ist doch beruhigend. Gut.
Aber was äh was also insgesamt, wie das so interpretiert wird, vieles eben, auch was du sagtest, wenn da erstmal ein Standard ist, das,
Dann geht damit halt eine gewisse Legitimation einher, ja? Und äh.
Das ist schon mal an sich problematisch.
Das ist schon mal an sich problematisch. Insofern ist es auf jeden Fall besser oder wär's schöner für uns, wenn äh die PI oder so da eben nicht als Standard äh verabschiedet fühlen.
Aber das wird vermutlich passieren oder.
So interpretiere ich Andres Artikel, ja.
Okay. Na, beunruhigend.
Und jetzt? Jetzt lustig. Google ist eine Taliban.
Ach ja. Doch. Doch, doch. Herr Käse, oder?
Doch, doch, doch. Herr Käse. Und.
Die hunderttausendste.
Ei, echt schön. Na, der das ist ein Goldzitat.
Ja, jetzt steigern sie sich aber auch wirklich.
Also der ja, Leistungsschutzrecht ist ja dem der geneigten äh Lokbuchnetz-Politik-Hörerinnen ein Begriff,
Und jetzt wird's ja äh jetzt wird's hart, jetzt wird's.
Die heiße Phase kommt.
Heiße Phase und ähm erstmal äußerte sich dann der ähm Döpfner,
von von Axel Springer Verlag in der Zeit in einem Interview über Google ähm,
zu der Kampagne, die Google da gestartet hat. Wir hatten ja.
Döpfner hat das gesagt.
Ja, der Döffner, äh das war interessant. Äh wir hatten ja darüber, wir hatten ja über die Kampagne gesprochen, dass äh dass Google jetzt auf der Startseite hat, rette dein Netz, ja? Und da wurde dann von Seiten des Springer Verlags äh richte sich der Döpfner dann da tierisch drüber auf,
Das äh also jetzt zeigt sich das Antlitz diese Firma, nutzt ihre Macht ähm zum politischen äh Agenda Setting auf der Startseite. Das würden Verlage nie machen.
Nein.
Nein, nein. Also ne, die die Bild äh Titelseite ist auch immer leer, ne? Da ist auch keine,
politische Message drauf, schon gar keine, die jetzt nicht lupenrein wäre, ganz klar von Ihnen, also reiner Informationsgehalt ohne irgendwie
Ja, also es ist ganz klar, da sieht man und ähm er kritisierte also dieses Vorgehen und sagte, also Google, die jetzt hier das,
freie Netz retten wollen auf ihrer Startseite, dass
sagte er wörtlich dazu, es ist jetzt schwierig, man der Sinnzusammenhang erschließt sich einem da jetzt nicht direkt. Das liegt jetzt nicht an meiner Schilderung. Er sagte, das ist so, als würde eine Helabande bei Amnesty International, eine Menschenrechtspetition zur Verteidigung der freien Bürgerrechte beim Ladendiebstahl einreichen.
Klar. Hä? Also ein schöneres Bild kann man für diese Kampagne von Google da gar nicht finden.
Bei Amnesty International kann man jetzt Petitionen einreichen.
Ja. Für Bürgerrechte bei Ladendiebstahl.
Aha.
Also mit anderen Worten Google, wir können das ja mal versuchen, wir können es ja mal versuchen zu analysieren. Also Google begeht Ladendiebstahl. Beruft sich dabei auf die freien Bürgerrechte.
Ladendiebstahl. Mhm.
Beruft sich beim Laden DJ auf die freien Bürgerrechte und macht deshalb eine Petition, also die freien Bürgerrechte ist jetzt also dann da, was ist jetzt die freien Bürgerrechte.
Weiß ich auch nicht, was jetzt die freien Bürger gibt's auch unfreie Bürgerrechte, also ja, dir Bürgerrechte wahrscheinlich an sich die Verteidigung der Bürgerrechte, meint er wahrscheinlich mit die freien Bürgerrechte.
Ja. Unklar, sagen wir mal so, aber also Google ist auf jeden Fall wie eine Hehlerbande, die.
Ja kurz gesagt, er bezeichnet sie sozusagen als Kriminell. Helabande.
Er bezeichnet sie als grünell. Ja, und dann war dann äh Herr kurz darauf gab dann der ähm Herr Käse, Christoph Käse, äh,
Mister Leistungsschutzrecht könnte man sagen. Ein ein Interview.
Ja, also. Was ist eigentlich dessen offizielle Rolle bei bei Lobbyist? Es hast du seine Berufsbezeichnung?
Da geht's ja dann nochmal irgendwie eine andere äh eine andere Benennung für, aber äh Journalist und Lobbyist ist er laut Wikipedia und wenn ich mich nicht täusche, hat er.
Außer einfach Lobbyist. Passt doch.
Lobbyist, ja. Und,
Na ja, also der sagte in einem Interview mit dem Magazin Horizont,
Da wurde ihm dann vorgeschlagen, er könnte sie doch ähm er könnte doch einfach Google bitten äh sich,
die Angebote des Axel-Springerverlages nicht ähm nicht zu injizieren. Und dann sagte er,
ja ähm wie soll das denn gehen? Jetzt sagen sie über die Robots TXT.
Und was geschieht dann? Man wird bei jeder Suchmaschine und jedem Aggregator unsichtbar. Ad, das ist nicht richtig.
Das ist nicht richtig, lieber Herr Käse, da muss ich, bevor wir jetzt hier zum Klimax der ganzen Äußerungen kommen, muss ich da jetzt nochmal Sachlichkeit walten lassen. In einer Ruhrpotts TXT, kann man sehr klar definieren,
Für wen man beabsichtigt, äh sichtbar zu sein und für wen nicht?
Ich schaue mir jetzt gerade mal die Roberts TXT von ähm Bild DE an, ja? Und da steht nämlich, wunderschön drin, User-Agen Doppelpunkt Web Reper, Doppelpunkt Slash,
der der Web Rea Crawler darf sich die Bild DE Seite nicht anschauen,
wird es entsprechend der allgemeinen Regulation dann auch nicht tun oder dem allgemeinen Konsens, wie man bei einer äh einer Roberts TXT verfährt. Weiterhin,
erlauben sie keinem Test slash Sternchen anzugucken und eine,
und anderes Zeug. Das heißt, sie haben eine sehr klare,
Definition, was sich welcher Qualer anschauen darf. Und genau dafür ist die Roberts TXT da. Und man kann in seine Roberts TXT auch reinschreiben. Ähm.
Dass man nur bei Google nicht sein soll.
Dass man ähm bei Google und mit Sicherheit auch, da bin ich jetzt etwas vorsichtig, aber ich bin mir sehr, sehr, sehr sicher, dass man die Google News Craller spezifisch auch ausschließen kann,
und dann trotzdem bei.
Es geht ihnen ja auch gar nicht nur um Google News. Natürlich. Aber wenn's ihnen um Google geht, weil das ja eine Hillerbande.
Dann sollen sie einfach schreiben Useragen äh.
Ja, Google go.
Google, der hat einen Namen. Wie auch immer, ich geseh den ab und zu meinen Server so,
Das dauert nicht lange, dann lässt der Google dich in Ruhe. Ähm aber wunderschön, also diese diese Robotstickste ist eigentlich seitdem es Webquarler gibt anerkannter Standard, an den sich alle halten. Das ist ja auch das, was der,
Ähm wie heißt der? Der nicht der kleine Tatortkommissar.
Weiß gar nicht, worauf du hinaus.
Sigi Schulz, Jimmy Schulz, Jimmy Schulz von der FDP, der hat Ähnlichkeit mit dem kleinen Tatortkommissar aus Stuttgart.
Ah, kenne ich nicht.
Der mit dem Porsche fährt. Find, finde ich, ich verwechsle die manchmal. Jimmy Schulz, weil der hat auch so einen auch so einen englischen Vornamen oder so.
Durchguckt nicht so viel.
Ich äh ich auch nicht. Liebe GEZ, äh ich habe keinen Computer, kein Fernseher, kein gar nix. Also Tatort weiß ich überhaupt nicht. Ich sehe das manchmal auf, ich habe davon gehört. Ähm,
Also ja okay, auf jeden Fall Jimmy Schulz betont ja und sagt, er möchte im Prinzip einfach nur, dass die Angaben in Robots CXT rechtlich verbindlich werden. Das ist sein Alternativvorschlag zu der Idee eines Leistungsschutzrechtes.
Darauf dafür plädiert Jimmy Schulz immer.
Richtig verbindlich im Sinne von dass das nicht nur freiwillig zu beachten beachtet werden soll, sondern zu beachtet.
Beachtet werden muss.
Muss, genau.
Das ist Jimmy Schulz, Alternativvorschlag als Mitglied der äh FDP
Die äh grundsätzlich ja pro Leistungsschutzrecht agiert. Das ist das, was er sagt, äh würde er für eine minimalinvasive Alternative zum Leistungsschutzrecht halten. Und das würde im Prinzip auch nichts ändern, weil an die Roberts TSC Angaben hält sich eh jeder.
Vielleicht nicht unbedingt jeder, aber wer es dann nicht tut, der äh macht sich halt auch irgendwie schuldig.
Ist ein ist eigentlich kein keine unsinnige ähm Idee.
Null Komma durchaus drüber diskutieren. So, aber Döpfner meint jetzt, er hätte da also Taliban äh genau, also.
Also Käse sagt.
Döpfner meint, das sind so äh Hela und äh äh Käse meint, es wären äh Taliban.
Also Käse
Käse äh lügt erstmal und oder oder weiß trotz alledem nicht, dass eine Robert Sixte tatsächlich so eine Unterscheidung ermöglicht und sagt
An- oder aus für alle und alles, das ist die einzige Wahl, die einem Robots TXT lässt.
Diese Technologie stammt aus der Steinzeit des Webs. Sie ist hoffnungslos veraltet und in keiner Weise mehr zukunftstauglich. Darauf haben die Verlage schon vor einem halben Jahrzehnt
hingewiesen. Sie haben dafür geworben, dass Maschinen lesbare Rechtesprachen entwickelt werden, die differenziertere Nutzungs differenzierte
Bedingungen ausdrücken. Warum soll ein Verlag nicht sagen dürfen, für wen und in welchen Auszügen ein Text für welchen Preis gewerblich kopierbar oder kopierbar sein
oder nicht kopierbar sein soll. Google ist eine Art Taliban und wehrt sich gegen jede Art von Fortschritt.
Das ist wirklich geil, Google.
Google.
Kugeln. Ich habe mich, ich ärgere mich auch immer wieder. Es ist diese weißt du, wer hält uns.
Super ey. Diese Springertruppe ist echt geil. Also Döpfner hat sozusagen was sagte er, äh Google hätte seine Maske abgenommen? Ja. Sagt er das? Du sagtest das.
Ja, irgendwas. Irgendwie soweit ich es. Äh ich ich habe jetzt nur diese Zitate rausgesucht. Ich weiß nicht, wer da wer da noch seine Maske abgenommen. Die.
Ich könnte mir das lebhaft vorstellen, wie Döpfner irgendwie zu Google sagt und so, nimm deine Maske ab, zeig dein wahres Gesicht.
Genau, das stimmt, der hatte irgendwas gesagt, diese bunten Buchstaben äh suggerieren uns.
Ja, genau, er hat ihn ja Erzkapitalismus vorgeschlagen.
Ja! Vor nicht vorgeschlagen, vorgeworfen! Vorgeschlag.
Vorgeworfen. Genau, Entschuldigung, weiß ich auch. Das das fand ich, also da da musste ich schon so ein bisschen innehalten oder so. Ah ja, okay, was war jetzt gleich Springer nochmal? Also äh das äh ist wirklich interessant, ne?
Also der Springer Verlag reißt Google äh die Maske ab und ich glaube Google kann.
Beruhigt.
Dazu einfach nur sagen, ja ich ich bin dein Vater.
Na Google, äh das das Schlimme. Ich finde das eigentlich fürchterlich wie Google, ja und die gesamte Menschheit, so in dem zwanzigsten Jahrhundert, festhält, ja? Keine Innovation, kein Fortschritt, ne. Äh.
Ausgerechnet von der Verlagsbranche. Also das ist schon wirklich, da muss man schon echt ganz schön also ich frage mich wirklich, was die eigentlich nehmen da.
Ist geil, ne? Ist geiler.
Also da da muss es irgendwie, also die Quelle hätte ich gern mal.
Also ich ich muss auch sagen, also der das ist echt geil. Geiles Zeug, ey. Also krass, ne. Ich was willst du da noch zu sagen?
Was willst du da noch zu sagen? Nee, da können wir jetzt auch nichts mit zu sagen. Lass uns zum nächsten Thema kommen.
Ich will noch eine äh kurze Anmerkung machen und zwar bei den bei den.
Ach so, warte mal, hat's du denn den Eindruck, was ist denn dein Eindruck jetzt Leistungsschutzrecht? Ich meine, es gab ja diese erste sogenannte Lesung und jetzt wird halt weiter äh fleißig gestrichen. Ich ich gehe ja irgendwie immer noch davon aus, dass sie damit nicht durchkommen,
Also vielleicht, ich will ich will nicht sagen, ich ich werde Recht behalten. Ich sage nur, ich kann's mir nicht vorstellen. Also es ist einfach so was von äh absurd und unsinnig.
Also ich will wir haben da ja letzte Mal schon so kurz drüber gesprochen, die ähm ich sehe gerade nicht, woran es scheitern kann.
Dass Leute dagegen sind? Hm? Petition gescheitert.
Es kann äh wie schon Zensursula einfach scheitern an einer,
äh an einer vielleicht sich noch steigernden Öffentlichkeit. Ich meine, also okay, ich schätze das,
Empörungspotenzial ist natürlich deutlich niedriger, das haben wir schon mit dieser Petition gesehen und so weiter, ist mir schon klar. Also es wird jetzt nicht so eine Welle der Straße sein, aber es könnte so eine juristische Welle sein,
weil einfach dieser Gesetzestext, ich meine, wir haben uns ja hier auch schon ein paar Mal angeschaut, man wechselt ja auch immer wieder, aber eigentlich steht da halt nur drin, äh ihr ihr seid alle böse und riecht nach Lulu und äh gibt uns euer Geld.
Es steht nächstes Jahr.
Und äh äh das das ist ja kein Gesetz. Ja, das ist ja also ich meine das
damit kommt man doch juristisch nicht durch. Das ist dann einfach wirklich so ein Einzelfallding mit hier äh Google verdient Geld und, und, und, und, und, und das steht uns zu. Das kann ja wohl äh nicht ernsthaft die Basis eines Gesetzes sein. So und gerade auch mit so einem großen
Widerstand aus der, aus der Wissenschaft, ja hier sogar, dass Max
äh Plank-Institut, ja, diese Urheberrechts äh Spezies, die alle nur äh geschlossen mit dem Kopf schütteln. Ich kann mir einfach nicht vorstellen, dass ich das juristisch halten wird. Und das ist dann vielleicht genauso, dass es vielleicht das zweite Mal so ein Auflösungsgesetz geben muss
um diesen ganzen Scheiß einfach wieder rückgängig zu machen, wenn sie dann irgendwie winsend endlich den Schwanz eingezogen.
Ich bin auf jeden ich bin sehr gespannt. Also da, das das auf jeden Fall. Aber ich will noch zu unserer äh zu unserer letzten Folge kurz etwas nachschieben, denn da sagte ich ja,
Da habe ich ja argumentiert, dass der Plan eigentlich ein anderer ist oder dass der dass der dass äh das Springern natürlich nicht,
Plan von Google Geliste zu werden und da habe ich dann auch einen schönen Link nochmal zu gefunden, der äh allerdings schon äh aus dem Juli stammt, wo,
ganz klar äh gesagt wird, Axel Springer-Konzern warnt Google, ja? Und zwar geht es darum, dass das,
der ist auch Christoph Käse im Interview mit mit äh Golem wohl. Ähm,
wo er sagt, na ja, passt mal auf, Google ähm,
vor irgendwie euer euer Kartell macht, äh wäre ich, mit der wäre ich vorsichtig, wenn ihr euch da nicht irgendwie noch mehr Ärger einfangen wollt, dann geht das echt äh schief, wenn ihr auf einmal Leute die listet.
ja? Ähm die Stellungnahme könnte als Drogen eines für den Marktbeherrscher zu verstehen sein,
für den Fall, dass Verlage ihre Forderung nach Vergutgütung aufrecht erhalten. Ein beim Aussprechen sollte solcher Drogen, sei es Rad ratsam, dass Wettbewerbsrecht im Auge zu behalten.
Ja, also da, das ist schon ganz klar, dass sie also sagen, wenn ihr uns da die listet und nicht zahlt, dann äh kommen wir euch über äh Kartellbeschwerden.
Das war ja das, wo wir, wo wir letzte Woche noch kurz drüber spwaren. Also diese Idee ist da auf jeden Fall auch im Raum. Gleichzeitig verlinke ich aber noch einen Artikel aus dem Februar,
wo Andrea Lose bei Arbeitsinfo schrieb, dass sie nicht davon ausgeht, dass die Verlage mit ihrer Kartell-Idee äh gute Karten haben, wenn sie sich mit, wenn sie sich da mit Google anlegen. Ich bin da persönlich, ich bin jetzt nicht Kartellrechter
Ich habe da wenig Ahnung von. Es bleibt auf jeden Fall spannend.
Ja, ich kann mir das auch nicht so richtig vorstellen. Also da wirklich jetzt so eine Absprache äh zu definieren. Das wird ihnen nicht so gelingen, glaube ich. Naja.
So sieht's auf jeden Fall aus. Steinzeit Google, echt fürchterlich.
So, wie sieht's denn aus in Syrien? Die haben wieder Internet.
Arbeiten, gehen sie weiter, hier gibt's nichts zu sehen.
War anders. Wie lange haben die Wartungsarbeiten gedauert?
Vierundzwanzig Stunden oder so.
Mhm. Kann schon mal sein, ne?
Also es gab irgendwie in diesem heise Artikel, das war ganz cool, da da stand dann von stand das irgendwie diese es gibt ja sehr viele, die irgendwie den den Gesundheitszustand des ähm des Internets überwachen,
wo du dann auch sowas visualisiert siehst und da meinten sie, dass es irgendwie drei IP-Pakete,
Also zwei Tage waren sie platt. Und äh dass sie irgendwie festgestellt haben, dass irgendwie drei drei,
sechs IP-Pakete von drei verschiedenen Absendern in Syrien angekommen sind, während der achtundvierzigstündigen Funkstille,
frage mich jetzt, was so mit einzelnen Handverlesen IP-Pakete sind da wohl noch irgendwie durchgekommen, ja.
Das war wahrscheinlich die Helaware von Google.
Das war die Lederware, die Kugel ins Land, gell?
Also auf jeden Fall, da gibt's wieder Internet während, wie wir alle wissen, in Ägypten auch grade mit Internet äh wieder äh sehr viel, sehr viel Unruhe äh herrscht, aber das sind nicht Netzpolitik, insofern.
freuen wir uns auf jeden Fall, dass das wir Syrien wieder im Internet begrüßen dürfen.
Ja, ansonsten, ich war, äh, das erste Mal auf dem, ähm, wie heißt das nochmal gleich, der Abend offiziell, der.
Netzpolitischer Abend oder so?
Abend oder so, also dieses monatliche Treffen von der digitalen Gesellschaft. War das erste Mal, da war ich bisher immer verhindert war, also wirklich immer,
Es war äh ganz angenehm und auch gut besucht. Da fiel mir dann ein Projekt auf, was dort vorgestellt wurde. Ich dachte, das könnte man jetzt hier am Rande auch nochmal erwähnen und zwar das äh,
Doppelpunkt Index oder auch Digital Openess Index, digitaler Offenheitsindex,
interessante Idee noch in der Entstehung begriffen,
Äh es sind so Österreicher, die das äh vorantreiben, aber die das durchaus jetzt nicht nur in Österreich äh machen wollen, der Gedanke ist, dass man hier,
eine ähm ähm alle,
Also es ging so ein bisschen davon aus, von so Initiativen wie LINUX in München, äh weiß ja Open Saurs einführen, Open Data, et cetera. Also einfach diese ganzen Sachen ins Government zu bekommen.
Und ähm viele dieser Projekte hatten ja,
Schwierigkeiten dann auch den entsprechenden Erfolg äh zu verbuchen und hier möchte man sich,
bemühen, Standards zu schaffen und Begriffswelten zu schaffen, die eine Messbarkeit eines solchen Erfolgs,
ermöglichen, so dass man eben auch die Umsetzung von solchen offenen Strategien in Gemeinden und Städten,
vergleichen kann. Ja, also so im Idealfall so ein Index dann eben erstellt
wo man sagen kann, ja hier im Bereich Open Source, ja, Anwendung von Open Source in Behörden, da seid ihr eben jetzt so weit gekommen, auf Basis, auf Maßgabe eben unserer Definition, welche Fortschritte dort äh,
denkbar sind. Genau das gleiche eben auch für äh Offenlegungen von äh Datenquellen et cetera PP. Und da werden auch noch Mitstreiter gesucht,
um genau einfach erstmal diese Definition,
vorzunehmen, ne? Also es wendet sich halt explizit da so an öffentliche äh Körperschaften in verschiedensten,
Rund um offene Daten, Informationen, Wissen und auch Infrastruktur.
Sogar einen Job.
Äh Projektkoordinatorin gesucht, ja.
Mhm.
Genau, das Ganze geht hier auch äh also obwohl ja jetzt Österreicher dahinter stehen, der ist äh ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht, wie er heißt, aber.
Leonatorisch.
Genau der ähm ist an der FU Berlin beschäftigt.
Als Junior-Professor für Organisationstheorie und auch äh aktiv äh bei digitaler Gesellschaft. Daher wahrscheinlich auch seinen Vortrag beim Netzpolitischen Abend der.
Genau, genau, genau.
Also alle mit einem abgeschlossenen Sozial- oder Wirtschaftswissenschaftlichem Hochschulstudium mit Diplom oder Master können sich äh bewerben bei Leonhard bei der FU,
Dahlem, ne? So weit fahren.
Drauf an, wo man wohnt.
Ja, man wohnt halt nicht in Dahle. Nee, schön.
So viel zum zum Internet in dieser Woche.
Ja. War jetzt war jetzt ein bisschen äh bisschen wenig.
Sorry.
So ist das manchmal.
Ich fand, ich fand das war gar nicht mal so schlecht, das heute mal ein bisschen weniger war und bisschen ruhiger. Ich habe, ich habe es genossen, eine ja. Ich finde es super.
Du hast es genossen. Ich hab's auch genossen. Ich mache ja eh grad ein bisschen ruhige Kugel und äh gehe hier also nicht ruhige Kugel in dem Sinn, dass ich gar nichts mehr mache, aber ich konzentriere mich derzeit mehr auf Infrastruktur.
Infrastruktur. Also ich kann das hier mit diesen Motorfeldern und dem iPad, also.
Nicht so gut.
Kurze nachgeschobene Info dieser ITU-Kongress läuft heute noch eine Woche, er läuft bis zum vierzehnten und dann ist er insgesamt elf Tage gelaufen.
Ah okay, meine Güte, die lassen sich aber Zeit.
Na ja, ich meine, wenn da irgendwie die alle Länder der Welt und ihre Lobbyisten sitzen.
Für Klimawandel lassen sie sich nicht so viel Zeit, glaube ich.
Ich gucke mir noch.
Für den Klimawandel schon, aber die Rettung.
Herr Klimawandel lässt aber auch auf sich warten, also äh ich gucke mal, Windsurf hatte sich, glaube ich, noch zu der ITU gemeldet. Das das verlinke ich dann noch.
Dagegen. Der mich mal kennengelernt, das ist wirklich ein, ein, ein, ein, ein netter Typ,
Auch einen geilen Job irgendwie bei Google, ne.
Intensiv Internet.
Ja, ich meine, das ist mal eine Berufsbezeichnung, oder?
Das ist mal echt die,
Er ist halt auch er ist halt auch äh äh Internet-Event ist, ich an mir scrollte vor ein paar Tagen ein ein großartiges Bild vorbei, das das suche ich jetzt noch schnell raus hier von ähm,
von Windsurf und wer bei der war im Fernsehen und unter seinem Namen stand Windsurf Web Developer.
So kann man das natürlich auch sehen.
Was halt stimmt, weil er hat das Web halt entwickelt so. Findest du nicht?
Nee, hat er nicht. Findest du nicht? Nee, das Web hat er nicht entwickelt. Das steht immer noch äh Herrn Börners Leh zu.
Okay, er hat das Internet entwickelt.
Ja, das muss man schon unterscheiden, ne? Und äh ja, von daher ist ja eher Internet, Developer, aber das trifft die Sache auch eigentlich nur sehr äh sehr begrenzt, ne?
Aber ist schon ich finde.
Ich hatte mal tatsächlich mal die Gelegenheit, mit ihm hintereinander, also er hat einen Vortrag gehalten und ich habe einen Vortrag gehalten am selben Ort. Das fand ich echt ganz lustig.
Und was war das?
Da bin ich mal nach Japan äh eingeladen worden. Das war so ein etwas skurriles äh Treffen der japanischen,
ähm Wirtschaftselite. Die treffen sich da irgendwie so einmal im Jahr und äh,
an alle möglichen Leute ein und auf äh dubiosen Umwegen äh bin ich da sozusagen auch mit hinein geraten und gehörte dann eben zu dieser illustren Runde, wo ich äh,
tatsächlich direkt neben äh vortragen konnte, aber na ja.
Neben ihm vortragen oder nach ihm. Okay.
Gut Linus, lass uns das hier äh beenden.
Bringt wieder neue Apple Produkte.
Klingelt auch schon wieder und äh wir sagen einfach mal tschüss, ne? Bis bald, ciao.